Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: Dr. Bright is not allowed
to classify any researcher, including himself,
as a memetic hazard!
Memetic hazards are not to be taken lightly.
Many of the SCP Foundation's best and brightest
have been cut down in their prime by memetic
hazards that ate away at their sanity and
destroyed their minds.
Just because Dr. Bright likes singing "The
Song that Never Ends" and annoying everyone,
that does not make him a memetic hazard by
Foundation standards.
Other behaviors that do not qualify a researcher
as a memetic hazard include but are not limited
to: whistling all the time, clipping their
nails at their desk, or microwaving fish in
the break room.